metal gear solid 5 the Phantom Pain's
release date has been announced
accidentally whoops this is Daniel Dwyer
with a gamespot breaking news update the
next entry in the Metal Gear Solid
series metal gear solid 5 the phantom
pain will be released worldwide on
September first 2015 I can't down on the
game's official size suggests that the
release date was going to be announced
tomorrow however nibble a vigilant
member on NeoGAF discovered a video with
italian subtitles which apparently had
been posted to IGN the video features an
interview with series creator Hideo
Kojima and reveals a release date of
September first hi this is Daniel Dwyer
with a game father first happy to
announce that the rest' 8 of half-life 3
is no no no no no no no as of the time
of this recording there has been no
confirmation from either Kojima
Productions Konami or IGN but the video
is floating around on YouTube right now
and looks pretty legit metal gear solid
5 the phantom pain is scheduled for
release on xbox one xbox 360 playstation
4 playstation 3 and the personal
computer for more news on metal gear
solid 5 the phantom pain and accidental
leaks from our competitors stay tuned to
gamespot com